The longest anyone has
gone without laughing
has been like 10 jokes.
Let's see if you can beat that.
- All right.
- All right so here we go.
Try not to laugh.
- Okay.
- Okay you ready?
Don't laugh.
Have you seen Forrest Gump?
- Yes.
(hysterical laughter)
- Already!
- Was that the shortest ever?
- It's the camera.
I told you it'd end real quick.
I can't, I can't do it,
I can't do a camera,
that's the bigger problem.
All right.
- Okay, you can just look at me.
- Okay, I'm gonna look at you.
Oh yeah, now this would be easy.
- Have you seen the movie Forrest Gump?
- I have.
- Do you know what his
Facebook password is?
- What?
- One Forrest One.
- That's pretty good.
- Okay.
Look back at the camera.
(laughter)
- I can't do the camera.
- Aright, let's see.
(hysterical laughter)
- What did the traffic
light say to the car?
- What?
- Don't look, I'm about to change.
(awkward bouncy music)
- What did the rubber band factory worker
say when he was fired?
- What?
- Oh snap!
(laughter)
- If you're cheese with
no cracker. what are you?
- What?
- Cracka Lackin'.
- Okay, good.
- You're cracka lackin'.
- Not gonna do it I'm afraid.
- Why does Snoop Dogg
always have an umbrella?
- I don't know.
'Cause it's raining cats and dogs?
- No.
- Oh.
- Fo drizzle!
- Oh, it was close.
- Why?
- Fo drizzle!
- Okay.
(laughter)
I tried so hard.
Cracka lackin', oh my
gosh, that's so dumb.
- Who's the smallest basketball
player who ever lived?
- Your mom.
(laughter)
Is that it?
- No, it's not.
- Who is it?
- What's the chiropractor's
favorite dance move?
Oh, no no no.
I'm sorry I messed up.
- Was that the joke?
'cause it worked.
- What did the traffic
light say to the car?
- I don't know.
- Don't look. I'm about to change.
(hysterical laughter)
Why don't candle trimmers
work Monday through Friday?
- Don't know.
- 'Cause they only work on wick-ends.
(laughter)
- That was hard.
I didn't make it very long did I?
- What's a magicians' favorite dance move?
- Uh.
Vanish.
- No, abraca-dab-ra.
- Mhm mhm.
- No?
- Have you heard of
the movie Constipation?
- No.
(laughter)
- Was that four?
Sorry, it was about poop.
(laughter)
- Have you heard it before?
- No.
(laughter)
- What is it?
I wanna know.
- Okay, so let's try that one again.
Have you heard of the movie Constipation?
- No.
- Hasn't come out yet.
(laughter)
Hasn't come out yet.
- See.
- So we would have laughed anyway.
- See, I would've lost anyways.
- What did the traffic
light say to the car?
- I don't know.
- Don't look. I'm about to change.
- Have you guys seen
the movie Forrest Gump?
- (numerous responses) Yes.
- What's his Facebook password?
(violin music)
Okay, I'll tell you.
It's One Forrest One.
- What do you call a
guy with a rubber toe?
Roberto.
- Wow. Roberto.
- (numerous responses) Wow!
- Groan.
- Why did the shrimp
keep all his treasure?
He was being a little shellfish.
- These are bad.
(laughter)
- What did one hat say to the other?
- I don't know.
- You stay here. I'll go on a 'head'.
- Oh!
(laughter)
- Why was the sand wet?
- It was near the ocean.
- No, because the sea weed.
(laughter)
- Oh my God.
I'm glad you didn't ask me that one.
- How do you make a tissue dance?
- No idea.
- You put some boogey in it.
(laughter)
- Oh God.
- You put some boogey in it.
- I actually like that's a cute one.
Yeah, I like that one.
- What do you call a guy with rubber toes?
- I don't know.
- Roberto.
- What did one hat say to the other?
- Oh, I don't know.
- You stay here,
I'll go on a head.
(laughter)
Take it.
- What do you call a pony with a cough?
- What?
- A little horse.
- Did you hear about the superhero
who lifts a lot and has a lisp?
- No.
- He's Thor.
- What did one hat say to the other?
- I don't know, what?
- You stay here, I'll go on a head.
- It's a good one.
- What do clouds wear under their pants?
- What?
- Thunderpants.
- Why didn't the shrimp
share any of his treasure?
- Why?
- He was being a little shellfish.
(silent laughter)
Finally, dang, my arm
was getting cramped up.
What do you call a bee on a bad hair day?
- I don't know.
- Frisbee.
- Did you hear about the
superhero with a lisp
that always works out?
- No.
- He's Thor.
(laughter)
- What's Forrest Gump's Facebook password?
- Jenny?
- No, it's one Forrest one.
(laughter)
- Why the shrimp share his treasure?
- Shrimp are greedy?
- He was being a little shellfish.
(laughter)
- All right, there we go.
- I like that one.
I like shrimp.
- Is this like musical chairs where
when you laugh you get kicked out,
and whoever stays--
- We can do that, yeah,
so if you laugh you have to leave.
- Yeah.
- Okay, here we go.
(laughter)
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- Stop, let her do it.
- Have you guys seen
the movie Forrest Gump?
- Yes.
- Do you know what his
Facebook password is?
- Forrest.
- One Forrest one.
- One Forrest one, get it?
- Okay, okay, okay.
- What did one hat say to the other?
- I don't know.
- You stay here,
I'll go on a head.
- No,
don't laugh.
(laughter)
Oh my God, you guys!
- I like the dumb ones.
- You're not supposed to laugh.
- What did the traffic
light say to the car?
- Stop.
- No he said "don't look,
I'm about to change".
- Oh my goodness.
- What did the rubber
band factory worker say
when he got fired?
- I'm gonna snap?
- He said "Oh snap!"
- Oh snap?
(laughter)
- Oh, you laughed.
- Why does Snoop Dogg always
carry around an umbrella?
- (simultaneously) I don't know, why?
- Fo drizzle!
(laughter)
- I'm out.
- What's drizzle?
- John's not hip enough.
- I don't know, I'm old.
- Have you guys heard of
the movie Constipation?
- No.
- Hasn't come out yet.
(laughter)
- Okay, that's not fair,
if we laugh at them laughing.
- Okay, why was the sand wet?
- It's all washed up.
- Because the sea weed.
- Oh my gosh, okay.
(laughter)
you laughed Jeron.
- Pam's ready to win this.
- Okay, if you're cheese with no cracker,
what are you?
- I don't know.
- You're cracka lackin'.
- What do you call a
bee on a bad hair day?
- I don't know.
- Frisbee.
- Why wasn't the shrimp
sharing any of his treasure?
- Don't know.
- He was being a little shellfish.
(laughter off-camera)
- Ooh that's a good one.
(laughter)
- Oh dude.
- You're the winner!
Good job!
- 'Cause here's why,
I am so used to listening to bad jokes,
that I can--
- No sense of humor,
she's not smart enough to get 'em.
That's the problem.
- Who do you hear the bad jokes from?
Him?
- He's the bad joker.
(awkward bouncy music)
- Hey guys, thanks for
watching (pop) another episode.
Before you go,
the most important thing I wanted
to tell you guys today is thank you.
Seriously, I don't think I
can ever thank you enough.
Because of you guys, I'm
able to share my work
with more and more people everyday.
I just really appreciate that
and I hope you guys know it.
(awkward bouncy music)